[Music]
in caffeine restriction so much weight
what's gonna have a do plan on having
kids okay see this is why I know that
I'm not ready because I can't do nine
months without sushi and I also don't
like like I feel like I can't snap back
I just don't have the motivation coffee
the coffee thing is a big one
well you can't you get any coffee boy
like they say you can't drink a little
bit by whatever the limit is a cup a day
but the problem is they recommend
nothing because there's caffeine and
beans that you don't know how like
chocolate or like people to open I'm
drinking a soda it's not a cup of coffee
but there's caffeine in there and then
so the the birth defects are that it's
almost the same thing as if the mom took
methamphetamines are you Seri there's
also high risk of miscarriage I can't
feel my like alright well no kids
submitted by it's not no caffeine it's
no pain give that up
wait did you not hear I got cute I did
see how cute but different was
philosophy
oh I never envisioned him having a
sister for some reason me neither
same but then forget a gender again as a
system a pretty much percent sure it's
gonna be a boy how do you a hundred
percent I feel like what should be a
girl like I'm so embarrassed are you
telling us you're pregnant
I wouldn't tell you like this okay
period literally right now so let's
argue with that or a tampon your sink
with Jess has a lot of stories to decide
if they want to serve kids under the age
of 16 a way to add away international
coffee team under 16 poster Kosta I
don't know how you pronounce it well you
can't get coffee if you're underage you
know they was there they want to
restrict right or they want to lift it
this is a london-based
coffee which is the second largest cat
puffy chain in the world and so now
they've allowed their restaurants or
coffee shops whatever to
strict beverages caffeine caffeinated
beverages to kids under the age of 16 so
this new policy has been in place in
some locations since the past summer but
now kids anymore they're teenagers they
should call them teenagers but then like
I feel like this is good I don't want my
kid to be like coming home caffeinated
like jumping off the walls this is the
weird part for me because if you know
the moment that I had kids I I want to
do the stuff that I want to do but I
don't want them to do the stuff that I
do so for example right I want to drink
soda but I want to give to them you know
I mean cuz I don't want them to you have
like those adverse effects that's the
hardest part that's the difficult thing
right I be mines the opposite like I
probably wouldn't drink soda because I'm
trying to Train but if they want soda I
don't want to limit their childhood the
way mine was limited kids also learned a
lot through observation so if we're
already not doing it and they want it
once in a while I'm not gonna be like
[ __ ] no well that's what I'm not gonna
say [ __ ] no strict yeah just you know be
smart about and hopefully I could be I
don't know I'm so scared I have kids
dude just because I have no self-control
job will be a reflection of me straight
up is that what daddy's having [ __ ]
soda it's like you're right god damn it
here have some soda the way that I was
raised is I really hired me to be my
fridge I would love to have every soda
in there and W coke squirt cactus cooler
sprite and just so it's fully stocked so
the kid feels loved and I probably might
drink a single one of them did you guys
all go up my family had a lot of soda
but my parents didn't drink it that much
so none of us really tried grew up
wishing I had a drop of juice in my
mouth but no I wrote without soda but I
didn't like I kind of wanted soda but
then now I I'm so thankful because my
friends are like I need a coke and I'm
like I don't need it yeah I didn't
really have a lot of soda I had soda
later on in life and that's why I've
actually had my first cavity is because
I started drinking soda a lot of
carbonated bread beverages and it [ __ ]
up my teeth yeah so I didn't have a
cavity until this in this until this
year just cuz I was drinking the [ __ ]
put a [ __ ] Diet Coke and Coke
Bartz he got me on that [ __ ] too dude I
was never into soda sand
grew up with only water and soy milk so
when I got the drink soda
oh yeah because my dad was like how did
you go your whole life without having a
cavity and I just never I never sweet
tooth either yeah coke mom what trips me
out is that parents are going or people
are just like oh yeah they shouldn't
have caffeinated anything but those are
the same people that allow their kids to
drink soda that has caffeine for me I'm
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
but I don't think they think about it
like they don't see coffee and soda is
the same [ __ ]
yeah one's gonna have more caffeine
content but you're consuming probably
more soda than you would coffee I
actually have a very unpopular opinion
but I think they should regulate sugar
and caffeine they should regulate sugar
and caffeine the way that they regulate
like other drugs and food install that
be dull and I've been drinking like
caffeine again pretty recently because
I've been training a lot more but I
didn't have it yesterday I couldn't
figure out why I had a huge migraine oh
I think I'm afraid of that's why I
purpose like if I need coffee I'm like
[ __ ] I'm gonna try to go as long as I
can until like I almost never drink
coffee but when you drink it I had the
best training sessions of my life
yep but I can't I don't want it I think
in the future and I'm like I ain't
trying to get no [ __ ] caffeine I was
waiting off a caffeine for the longest
time but I just think like cuz you know
we're all older now yeah and so I don't
have that abundant energy especially if
we're trying to train two hours and then
still [ __ ] do all of our business
[ __ ] till like 10 p.m. yeah I need
that's not normal working hours like you
need to I need something you know yeah
you stop caffeine after Rebecca
yeah hundred percent like just like
medicine I remember you love your Red
Bulls and all that dude like candy was
like just me I mean it's just easy for
me if I'm really passionate about that
thing I can just go cold turkey
but now I'm back you only drink coffee
maybe even like twice a week or so the
candies still [ __ ] going
well she did quit if you don't like it
that much anymore huh it's easy to quit
if you don't like it that I [ __ ] love
it dude I want to marry kandi I mean
like coffee back then though I was I was
really into coffee yeah so was i I was
like soda every single meal every day of
my life and then I got pregnant and I
found out the whole thing
I was like no soda no coffee no no
coffees really great for helping me go
poop though yeah so I always have it a
little bit in the morning and then it's
a natural accident I even take my
probiotic and then down it with coffee
and and you shoot your brains out I
didn't like you have a tight sphincter
yeah it's like being held it's a chamber
this is your butthole right now hold me
man yeah how come they don't want to
serve it to kids they're studies that
show like caffeine for people under 16
it's bad for them well they don't really
go into much detail as to why they
decided to implement this new policy but
they're just talking about how now this
is inciting online rage because it was
his dad who complained that coffee place
blocked his twelve-year-old daughter
from buying a coffee why would she need
coffee she's 12
what the [ __ ] cuz it's her occasional
treats oh but does that include like the
frappuccinos and stuff because then I
can see why the parents are like look
let her have like a green matcha
Frappuccino but frappuccinos are worse
now cuz it's high sugar and high
caffeine it's like the worst thing ever
you're gonna run a marathon why should
that much been exactly what I have
they're just doing a lot of [ __ ] with
coffee like it's doing the most like
isn't California now they're like
requiring to say like this product
contains can't like can cause cancer too
like coffee cups that's it's everywhere
it's the [ __ ] there's a type of paint
that they use like a lead paint or some
[ __ ] I can't even walk into certain
stores and you'll see it yeah yeah so a
lot of like these antique stores they
sell these old like ceramics that were
made with that specific type of paint no
they have to put the warning on there I
feel like that's giving me so much
stress that I'm gonna get cancer cancer
we're living yeah we've been living in
for yeah but I think you're right though
the more you're bombarded with that you
stress and then you know you can realize
the cancer yes absolute active though
because they want everyone to be afraid
of everything like
shampoos gonna cause you cancer
deodorant causes cancer but then the
following year they're like this other
new thing causes like every year it's
something else that causes can I'm the
opposite I hear all that [ __ ] on my
[ __ ] I must go to hospital where's
your cat's a refrigerator I'm gonna eat
that [ __ ] come on [ __ ] cancer
you don't make even if I get cancer that
I'm like awful if you win what that's
like I eat I would eat parasites
spaghetti and em I'll be like come at me
parasite I don't like what I know it's
all rather bad just avoid it altogether
but you can't I don't like anticipation
I think warning labels come from a good
place because you know they just want to
make sure that you know before you're
gonna go near that product or eat that
product or whatever because a lot of us
don't know like what healthy is or any
of that don't too much like that the
California one
it's like relax calm down we're sooo
happy here though they need those it's
more in there so it's really I think
that's what everyone wants to cover
their asses so they're just like I don't
know everyone yeah but it's so weird
though like having like kids who crave
coffee that is very like they're 12 is
like I need my morning even weirder
because the kiss the kids taste buds
aren't developed and [ __ ] up the way
adults are so the taste of coffee is not
good big beer you like kid that wants
beer all that money that acquired
tasting what it is is it's addiction so
you develop an acquired taste of things
that are addictive because it you know
it starts to taste good because that you
associate good feelings with it it's
just weird like I don't know what a 12
year olds like needs with a [ __ ] fat
cup of coffee like what the [ __ ] they're
just waking up as I well to this dude
was gonna be hard today you know what is
what is the purpose of it it doesn't
even taste good it's bitter it's very
accurate you know it's probably dessert
coffee yeah because I love dessert
coffee I couldn't drink black coffee
until way later in life oh but how would
you feel if your kid is 16 years old
they're on track they love studying
they're on track to be like the next
Elon mother freaking musk and they just
want coffee no they could [ __ ] smoke
crack if it's if that's the case I want
to take care of their health so you'd
start as a parent
like no nope I would not know cats like
you want me to get you some cocaine cuz
you're such a great [ __ ] kid I Got
You adderall cocaine man I was like
anything you're about dudes you're like
it's like Elon Musk
[ __ ] dude you should anything you want
to just tell me just tell me
[Music]